oh yeah yeah I came close twice to
actually losing my life I well one
happened in toronto canada the other one
happened in edgewater nova scotia i was
i was sealed up in a coffin they had
cables fastened to meet her and they
load lowered me into the I forgotten
lahav River i think it was outside
halifax i hope i got these names right
and they had telephone with me and
microphone headphones the whole thing
and i was there in the coffin there was
a huge crowd out on the embankment it
was some sort of a festival I don't
remember what it was exactly and they
connected me with my mother who was back
in toronto canada and the phone rang and
she picked it up and she said hello i
said hi this is your son she said he
sound funny and I said yeah i'm at a
confident at the bottom of the LA River
and she said oh come on and I said yes I
am and there's a whole crowd of people
out there listening to you she fell
silent a little stage struck i guess but
eventually she got over it and we had a
little bit of a chat and then i noticed
something very strange happening there
was mud started moons over the
transparent panel the glass panel i had
in the top of the coffin through which I
could see the daylight up above me and I
was under about six or eight feet of
water held down by barbells and various
things to wait me down and they had a
diver in beside me in an old diving suit
one with the big round headpiece and
held that that is and he saw that I was
slipping out of the harness and into the
mud at the bottom of the LA River and
but for his ingenuity I might still be
there someplace rather wasted and and
waiting for a rescue I would guess but
the the diver refitted the the loop of
table around the the coffin and I stayed
down for the rest of the time and they
finally hauled me up so that was very
close I could have drifted away down the
river there was a heavy current they
could have lost me old
other and what would the world be
without me I mean after all let's face
it then the other example was I got
locked up in a safe in toronto canada in
the sun newspaper office i wanted to do
a stout that they would remember me for
and they had this steel safe and I
jammed myself into it and barely got
into the van ty told me to close the
door and I would escape and my assistant
Moses was outside at the time and I'd
sir depended on him and he had to help
me out of this one too high i worked at
the door the compartment of the back of
the door and I saw the combination there
and then I felt the door coming out at
me and I knew what that meant it was
spring loaded in such a way that if
anyone tried to knock the mechanism out
of place borrowers would jump in at the
side of the safe and seal me and
permanently and they could only cut me
out with an acetylene torch and that
would take a long period of time at very
high temperatures and I wouldn't survive
that so I just said Moses and he said
yeah he's I said have them dial up the
combination on the safe so the manager
sat down and I heard zip zip zip zip zip
zip zip zip colt no zip zip zip zip zip
zip and I said Moses find the person who
opens it every morning and a lady came
over the manager was breaking down he
couldn't stand the attention so she
finally dialed it up and clicked the
door fell over and I fell out on the fly
past though as I fell out on the floor
as a matter of fact so that was the
second instance of my coming close to
cashing in